e
après ce long préambule
après ce long préambule alors
on va donc parler maintenant des
économies alors faire des économies
c'est très facile sur un objet donné
c'est extrêmement facile techniquement
faire des économies tout le temps et
partout
prenez un exemple ici qui est le
bâtiment vous avez une photo d'une
maison passive
installée dans un pays où il fait très
chaud en suède cette maison n'a pas
besoin d'accords le chauffage alors elle
a été conçue de telle sorte qu'elle en
ait pas besoin elle est très bien isolée
elle a des circulations d'air dans le
sol qui permet de préchauffer l'air en
hiver et de le refroidir en été elle a
des vitrages qui sont orientés larifou
l'un des auvents qui permettent d'éviter
le cagnard
quand le soleil est au zénith en été et
qui au contraire le font rentrer quand
il est bon en hiver et c'est alors
est-ce que ça ça s'appelle des économies
bah ça dépend au niveau d'un objet c'est
évident alors un exemple je dirais plus
répandue je vous prends un logement
construit en 1950
aujourd'hui si ce logement dispose d'un
chauffage central parce qu'en 1950 il
n'avait pas toujours un chauffage
central
vous êtes à 250 kilowatts heure par
mètre carré on est aujourd'hui passé à
des logements qui dont le sait la nar
main qui doivent consommer 80
kilowattheures par mètre carré et par an
donc trois fois moins d'énergie
consommée par m² de logements
quand on construit un logement il est
évident que c'est une économie
c'est absolument que c'est une économie
sauf que dans le même temps vous avez de
plus en plus de maisons qui dispose et
de deux immeubles qui dispose du
chauffage central
la surface habitable par personne est
passée alors en 73 étaient 25 mètres
carrés je sais pas de combien elle était
en 1950 mais à mon avis elle devait
probablement être sous les 20 à 40
mètres carrés
aujourd'hui donc par mètre carré - de
kilowatts heure par personne plus de
kilowattheures la population elle l a
augmenté et puis vous avez eu en plus du
chauffage
un certain nombre d'appareils qui sont
venus augmenter la consommation
et quand je vous le disais la population
a augmenté donc on a maintenant plus de
logement est-ce que ça c'est toujours
des économies si on compose les
économies par mètre carré qui ont été
réalisés avec les évolutions que je
viens de vous évoquer ici ça se discute
autre exemple en d'autres termes ce que
je suis ce dans quoi je suis en train de
vous faire rentrer actuellement c'est
quand on économise on économise par
rapport à quoi
l'histoire ne s'écrit qu'une fois donc
économiser c'est toujours dire ce qui se
serait passé si par définition si
j'avais pas acheter un aspirateur et
cologne j'en aurais acheté un gourmand
mais peut-être que si vous n'aviez pas
acheter d'aspirateurs économe vous
auriez acheté un balle est donc dans la
comparaison aspirateur économe vers
aspirateur gourmand on peut dire que
vous avez fait une économie par contre
si vous aviez acheté un ballet vous
n'avez pas fait une économie du tout
vous devez acheter un surplus de
consommation donc la question des
économies c'est toujours par rapport à
quoi
alors un autre exemple connu et archi
connus voici la voiture de mes grands
parents quand une voiture donc la deux
chevaux de 1950 une cylindrée et qui
aujourd'hui fait ricaner un retard
neuf chevaux de puissance de moteur 60
kilomètres/heure de vitesse de pointe
une demi tonne de pois et ça consomme
après 25 litres aux cent on se basera
données d'utilisation la douche chaude
aux temps modernes en voici une par
exemple elle a une cylindrée qui a été
multiplié par quatre elle a une
puissance de moteur qui a été multiplié
par 8
elle a une masse qui a été multiplié par
deux une vitesse de pointe qui a été
multiplié par 2,5 et elle conseille
toujours à peu près la même chose alors
il est clair que vos petits copains qui
ont cinq dix quinze ou vingt ans de plus
font dire
il ya énormément d'économies dans cette
affaire quatre fois moins de carburant
consommé par centimètre cube de cinar et
et puis vous voyez ici des multiples que
je viens de vous citer qui
réapparaissent tous c'est à dire que
vous êtes entre deux ennemis et cette
fois plus économe par unité du âge que
vous choisissez de prendre en compte la
vitesse de pointe hamas sa puissance
peu importe donc évidemment vous faites
des économies
et si vous regardez le discours du
patron de renault ou de peugeot il à
vous dire je fais plein d'économies
regardez amassés à puissance constante
parce que là vous avez affecter les
progrès de la technologie à
l'augmentation de la masse de la
puissance et de la vitesse mais dont
vous pouvez aussi vous dire que amassés
à puissance constante vous savez faire
des choses qu'ils consomment de moins en
moins et c'est parfaitement vrai encore
donc là il ya indiscutablement des
économies sauf que dans le même temps
les us en saas et le parc de voitures
dans le monde c'est la courbe bleue qui
est importante entre 1960 et aujourd'hui
il exactement 65
eh bien vous voyez que dans ce laps de
temps le parc de voitures à quadruples
et et je vous rappelle que la
consommation globale
c'est par définition la consommation
unitaire fois le nombre d'objets qu'ils
consomment et à chaque fois que vous
avez un débat sur les économies
d'énergie c'est toujours et toujours et
encore et toujours la même question qui
revient est ce que dans le même temps
diminué
vous n'avez pas pu raisonnablement une
augmentation de ce truc là qui va encore
plus vite et en fait vous allez vous
rendre compte que dans à peu près la
quasi totalité des usages c'est ce qui
s'est passé c'est à dire que le nombre
d'objets en circulation qui consomment
de l'énergie a crû plus vite que la
baisse de la consommation par objet qui
circulent
il n'ya rien d'hérétique là dedans si
vous vous rappelez ce que je vous ai dit
au premier cours qui est que la baisse
du prix réel de l'énergie est un élément
structurant du développement du dernier
siècle et demi si l'énergie coûte de
moins en moins cher et bien si un objet
donnée consomme moins d'énergie
vous avez un surplus de pouvoir d'achat
que vous allez affecté à acheter
d'autres trucs qui vont aussi consommer
moins en moins d'énergie du reste donc
en gros le l'augmentation du revenu
disponible en termes réels en termes
physiques fait que le résultat qu'on a
obtenu en faisant des objets qui
consomme moins d'énergie a très rarement
été une baisse de la consommation
globale des objets en circulation mais
une augmentation des usages
autre exemple vous avez ici à gauche le
frigo et la ménagère de 1950 et deux
dans un même paquet cadeau alors en 1950
qu'est ce que c'est le frigo c'est une
capacité d'environ 100 litres et c'est
une consommation électrique d'environ
400 kilowatts heure par an aujourd'hui
vous allez sur le site
darty kelkoo etc et on nous explique que
le frigo il fait à peu près le triple de
la capacité planète dans vous avez une
partie du compartiment dans lequel vous
atteignez des températures beaucoup plus
négative que ce que vous aviez en 1950
ce que vous avez un congélateur intégré
qui va occuper entre la moitié et les
tiers de l'espace
et tout ça pour 300 ridicule
kilowattheure pas donc effectivement par
litre refroidi vous avez 2 à 4 fois
moins d'électricité consommée et bien
par frigo aux etats unis la consommation
moyenne par figo a culminé entre 1600 et
1800 1864 an et par frigo avant de
redescendre aujourd'hui aux alentours de
400 sous l'effet des réglementations qui
ont été
voilà à l'évidence économie d'accord
vous prenez un frigo à l'évidence
économie je me rappelle encore une fois
que quand vous aurez des patrons il vous
demandera de réfléchir sur la
consommation d'énergie d'un frigo de
tous les frigos c'est plus rare voilà
l'ancêtre de votre micro ordinateurs
leygnac électroniques numériques al jeu
puis courant intégrateurs l'un des
premiers ordinateurs qui a été construit
dans le monde alors leygnac c'est quoi
ces 27 tonnes voilà 150 kilowatts de
puissance absorbée par balle et tout ça
pour 18 tubes à vide ridicule
aujourd'hui quand on veut reproduire
leygnac sur une puce informatique il
faut 300 milles transistor qui fait ce
qu'un truc qui fait se bidonner le
premier designer d'intel venu vous êtes
passé à ça là aussi vous avez la
ménagère en prime deux kilos et demi
50 millions de transistors quelques
dizaines de lettres de puissance
absorbée sur mon ordinateur mon
ordinateur il peut tenir quatre heures
avec une batterie qui doit faire 80
watts heure vous à peu près d'envoyer sa
bouffe
rien que ça bouffe varois tout 25 watts
voilà donc là vous commencez à avoir des
rapports qui donnent le vertige par
unité de masse ou par transistors
installez vous avez des rapports de 10.6
d'accord vous avez gagné un facteur à
millions d'économies on peut vite on
peut hein
ce que dans le même temps vous avez vu
ça que je vous ai déjà montré la
dernière fois et que je vous remontre
aujourd'hui c'est à dire que en 1970
soit en 1950 peu importe mais là je vais
prendre l'exemple de 1970 vos parents
avaient un réfrigérateur qui était un
infâme
une infâme passoire à calories les mieux
les mieux lotis d'entre eux avaient déjà
un congélateur qui était aussi une
infâme passoire à calories personne
n'avait de micro ondes puisque le micro
n'avait pas encore été mis au point un
commercialement personne n'avait de
sèche-linge puisque le sèche-linge
n'était pas encore disponible
commercialement très peu de gens avaient
un lave vaisselle
très peu de gens avaient un
lave-vaisselle le pc n'étaient pas
disponibles donc les gens n'en avait pas
et aujourd'hui on a évidemment des
frigos avec des rats et des étoiles
partout qui consomment pas d'énergie
sauf que chaque personne a rajouté à son
frigo india a des étoiles partout un
congélateur à égarer des étoiles partout
et un micro ondes à guéret des étoiles
partout et un lave linge avec des arrêts
des étoiles partout etc et le résultat
final de cette affaire le voici
c'est l'évolution de la consommation
d'électricité dans le monde et si vous
prenez la consommation d'électricité
dans les sols bâtiment en france on
l'appelle résidentiel et tertiaire
c'est pas une multiplication par 2 que
vous avez sur cette échelle 2 sur
l'échelle alors là c'est 80 de 1000 mhz
sur 73 2000 c'est pas une multiplication
par 2 vous avez une multiplication par
quatre pour que la consommation
d'électricité dans les bâtiments vous et
moi quand on est chez nous et vous et
moi quand on est dans un bureau a été
multiplié par quatre il n'ya par quatre
entre 1973 et 2000 déduction faite du
chauffage électrique je ne prends pas en
compte le chauffage électrique dans ce
que je vous annonce d'accord voilà
économie ou pas économie vous voyez bien
et je vais revenir un tout petit peu
plus tard que dans le problème qui nous
préoccupe c'est bien l'économie globale
que nous cherchons c'est pas l'économie
par objet l'économie par objet elle est
utile dans la mesure où à l'aide raconte
l'économie globale mais elle ne garantit
pas l'économie globale ça fait un siècle
et demi qu'on fait des progrès
techniques sur les voitures les avions
les ordinateurs et les fusée lunaire
en attendant la consommation d'énergie
ça n'a pas empêché d'augmenter à peu
près tout le temps et partout donc les
économies par objet encore une fois
c'est quelque chose qui aide mais ça
n'est pas suffisant pour savoir dans
quel sens va souffler le vent et pour
savoir dans quel sens va souffler le
vent allait faire ajouter autre chose
dont je vous parlais un peu plus tard
après il ya autre chose qui peut
quelquefois en ce qui concerne le cde
être mis en avant qui est de dire que
les économies il faut les faire là où
c'est économiquement plus intéressant et
je vous donne l'exemple de la
compensation
en ce qui concerne le co2 qui est dont
je vais vous expliquer le principe mais
qui peut s'étendre aux économies
d'énergie en gros on peut dire je vais
pas les faire moi je vais faire faire à
quelqu'un d'autre
en ce qui concerne le co2 la
compensation que s'appliquait à de
l'énergie ou à autre chose voilà quel
est le principe de notre affaire vous
êtes ici avec quelqu'un qui doit
économiser
donc il a deux éditions mais encore une
fois si c'était de l'énergie principe
restera le même il ya des émissions et
il regarde par le petit bout de la
lorgnette et avec beaucoup d'attention
quelqu'un d'autre qui a aussi des
émissions et puis va lui dire chez moi
c'est trop dur
donc je te donner de l'argent à toi et
chez toi ou c'est facile tu vas réduire
à partir du moment où vous êtes sur un
problème global
pourquoi pas hein vous pouvez dire chez
moi faire baisser la température dans le
foyer de l'école des mines c'est trop
dur mais je vais donner l'argent que
j'aurais éventuellement accepter de
dépenser pour traiter le problème de
l'énergie à quelqu'un d'autre chez qui
c'est beaucoup plus facile de traiter
problème alors la grâce et cet argent
l'entité à laquelle on s'adresse fait
baisser ses émissions ou fait baisser sa
consommation mais là en l'occurrence et
des émissions et à ce moment c'est là
qu'arrive la grande subtilité la
personne qui a donné l'argent dit ça ou
ça c'est barry d'accord les émissions
n'ont plus lieu
et comme c'est moi qui ai payé eh bien
je m'octroie le bénéfice du fait que les
émissions les plus lieu le principe de
la compensation c'est ça vous avez ce
principe qui est donc le protocole de
kyoto soit dit en passant c'est ce qu'on
appelle les mécanismes de développement
propres ou la présentation conjointe du
pas le temps de vous parler aujourd'hui
ce principe il existe il fait sens sur
les émissions puisqu'on a vu que enfin
en théorie si c'est bien fait il fait
sens sur les émissions puisque
vous avez vu que les gaz à effet de
serre avec dio et de résidences dans
l'atmosphère qui était de l'ordre du
siècle et donc à partir du moment où la
durée de résidence et de l'ordre du
siècle et où la durée de brassage inter
hémisphérique de l'atmosphère et de
l'art de l'année vous voyez bien que le
lieu d'émission n'a pas d'importance
et si je paye quelqu'un d'autre pour
réduire à ma place parce que c'est plus
facile pour lui parfois ça ça reste
physiquement quelque chose de pertinent
là on va commencer à avoir des ennuis
c'est que et c'est là que je vais en
revenir à l'histoire de mes économies
c'est que on va avoir le même problème
en ce qui concerne la compensation que
celui qu'on a en ce qui concerne les
économies d'énergie si je vous disais
économies par rapport à quoi
économie par rapport à quoi est bien
très souvent on va considérer que la
situation gauche et la situation de
droite sont identiques
c'est à dire que la situation dans
laquelle on empêche une augmentation
tendancielle de se produire est
identique à une situation dans laquelle
on a réduit qu'on devrait c'est ce que
je vous disais tout à l'heure ça c'est
le ballet la place de ce pirate heures
et ça c'est le petit à la place du gros
compte en acheter toute façon c'est quoi
la bonne manière dans cette affaire de
considérer les économies c'est quoi la
bonne manière
est ce que c'est ça ou est ce que c'est
ça chacun apporte sa réponse la vienne
et en dire qu'à partir du moment où la
contrainte
elle est globale et elle nous force à la
baisse que ça nous plaise ou que ça nous
plaise pas la bonne réponse est plus
loin de ça que de ça votre réponse est
plus près que ça que ça là bas voilà
c'est c'est quelque chose comme ça j'ai
pris l'exemple de la compensation pour
illustrer le déplacement des économies
et surtout le fait que le scénario de
référence et quelque chose d'absolument
fondamental pour conduire
il ya pour qu'on puisse dire pardon ya
eu économie où il n'y a pas eu économie
et dans la majeure partie des cas de
figure y compris dans les statistiques
nationales de vos anciens qui sont
installés
au ministère maintenant de l'écologie et
du développement durable on définit
souvent les économies d'énergie dans ce
genre de vision avec ce genre de vision
c'est à dire c'est ce qu'on aurait
consommé en plus si on n'avait pas fait
gaffe ça veut pas dire qu'on va
consommer moins c'est ce qu'on aurait
consommé en plus si on a été fait hier
est ce qu'il ya des choses qui vont nous
amener naturellement les économies
d'énergie sans qu'on ait besoin de se
lever du fauteuil 1 je vais vous donner
quelques exemples de choses qui
vraisemblablement ne marcheront quand
vous avez ici de cours et la mise en
perspective
alors la première et sur une échelle de
temps qui est beaucoup plus large que la
seconde
la première vous donne la structure de
l'emploi en france entre 1800 et 2000 a
alors en 1800 vous voyez les deux tiers
de la population ont poussé les patates
1 c'est l'emploi agricole qui domine
très largement
vous avez ici les emplois dans
l'industrie qui à l'époque représente à
peu près 20% de la population active et
les emplois dans les services qui à
l'époque représente à peu près 15
et si ma mémoire est bonne à cette
époque là les employés ce qu'on appelait
les employées de maison pour que tous
les gens qui servent les plafonds ménage
etc
c'était pas loin d'être la moitié si ce
n'est plus de cette population
vous voyez que le fil du temps on a
d'abord le développement de l'industrie
et puis depuis 1970 le développement
rapide des services et la baisse du
nombre d'emplois dans l'industrie en
part relative et ça c'est ce que tout le
monde appelle la dématérialisation en
disant ça c'est génial ça ça va nous
sauver c'est pas la peine que on se
préoccupe du problème puisque ça il ya
qu'à faire confiance aux ingénieurs des
mines ils vont nous faire internet et
des ordinateurs et comme ça on sera
sauvés quand tu vas voir que c'est pas
aussi simple que ça malheureusement
certes vous avez eu ici une très forte
croissance de la part dans les services
il n'empêche que sur la même période de
temps vous avez eu une croissance de la
quantité d'énergie consommée en france
donc si on voulait avoir une
démonstration irréfutable
eh bien il suffit à dire on ne comptera
pas dans les services et croque sa
dématérialise
et à ce moment on se met à avoir une
baisse de la consommation d'énergie bah
ça c'est aussi simple que ça c'est
d'autant plus compliqué que ici on
réserve en part relative et ça c'est
aussi un truc donc il faut souvent se
méfier je voulais pas souligner quand on
a vu la première fois la consommation
d'énergie mondiale
mais c'est pas parce que la part
relative du charbon a baissé depuis un
siècle et demi que la quantité de
charbon consommé en valeur absolue à
baisser
c'est exactement pareil la peintre
native de l'emploi dans l'industrie a
baissé il n'empêche qu'à l'heure à
laquelle je vous parle on a trois fois
plus d'emplois dans l'industrie qu'on en
avait en 1800 alors que vous voyez qu'on
part relative on est presque au même
niveau on est et on est aujourd'hui à 25
et on était à 20,1
mais en fait vous en avez trop soit plus
aujourd'hui donc si vous prenez comme
indicateurs le nombre d'emplois
industriels par hectares de sols
si vous prenez un référent qui bouge pas
au cours du temps par exemple le nombre
des cas un la surface de la planète et à
l'escalet bougera pas et bien là vous
vous rendez compte que la
dématérialisation est quelque chose qui
se discute énormément
une deuxième raison pour laquelle ça se
discute énormément c'est que vous avez
aujourd'hui dans les services d'état
d'emplois qui n'ont absolument rien à y
faire
je vais vous prendre un exemple la
distribution d'eau c'est dans les
services en attendant si vous allez voir
à quoi ressemble un distributeur dos et
des pompes et des tuyaux et des moteurs
par tous les gros travaux en béton ou
les machins etc il ya un siècle on
aurait mis ça dans l'industrie si vous
allez voir un opérateur de transport une
compagnie aérienne ou des gens qui font
avancer des bus c'est dans les services
en attendant c'est essentiellement de
l'énergie si vous allez voir les
services à l'énergie justement j'en
parlais des gens qui règlent des
chaudières etc ou qu'il est ou qui les
gère eh bien on va mettre ça aujourd'hui
dans les services en alternance et des
activités industrielles
donc il ya aussi un truc quand il faut
se méfier et ça je pourrais un tout qui
peut élargir le propos
dès que vous avez les statistiques vous
ne pouvez pas les interpréter si vous
n'avez pas accès à la banque la turquie
a défini ce que vous comptez kivu non si
vous ne savez pas comment on définit ce
qu'on compte
vous allez dire des conneries un très
bon exemple là dessus je vous ai pas
défini
b dont j'ai pourtant vous parlez et bien
je peux vous assurer qu'il ya des tas de
gens qui disent des tas de trucs sur le
pib qui sont des âneries grosse qu on
veut tout simplement parce qu'ils savent
pas comment se définit donc à partir du
moment où vous perdez de vue la manière
dont on définit les notions qu'on
manipule vous avez toutes les chances de
encore une fois vous trompez de
définition du problème au regard de
quelque chose qui est assez rigolo là il
ya quelqu'un qui s'est amusé à regarder
comment évoluer les émissions de co2 par
habitant en fonction de la part des
services dans l'emploi il a fait une
petite régression du dr là dessus alors
certes le taux de corrélation est pas
extraordinaire mais enfin la seule chose
qu'on puisse démontrer en gardant ce
graphique c'est qu'il suffit pas
d'augmenter la part des services dans
l'emploi pour faire baisser les
émissions de co2 ça c'est absolument
certain
ça s'explique tout ça ça s'explique
encore une fois par le fait que les
transports font partie des services par
le fait que pour mettre beaucoup de gens
dans un bureau il faut qu'ils aient
beaucoup de machines qui produisent à
leur place parce que quand vous êtes
dans un bureau ou pour disais rien
projet de la matière grise vous
produisez pas de patates et pantalon et
pas de chaise et pape table et pas de
logement donc pour qu'on ait beaucoup de
gens dans un bureau eh bien il faut que
par ailleurs on ait accumulé un gros
capital industriel qui est capable de
produire à de placer le capital
industriel lui il a besoin d'énergie
donc le fait qu' un pays est une part
importante de tertiaire dans ces
activités ne signifie pas en fait quand
vous regardez dans le monde c'est
exactement l'inversé ne signifie pas que
il a des consommations d'énergie qui
sont faibles le meilleur indicateur des
émissions de co2 d'origine énergétique
faible dans un pays je vous épargne la
cour mais j'aurais dû c'est la part de
l'emploi agricole
là par contre quand l'emploi agricole
dépasse 20 ou 30 % de la population
active
les émissions de co2 par tête gaza
figure logique
à partir du moment où les gens sont
touchants ils sont pas disponibles pour
faire tourner les usines
donc c'est parfaitement logique donc les
pays qui ont des faibles émissions de
co2 par personne
aujourd'hui ce ne sont pas les pays
fortement tertiarisée ce sont les pays
qui sont à économie fortement rural
c'est comme ça que ça marche
soit dit en passant ça veut dire que
toutes choses égales par ailleurs une
augmentation de la contrainte sur la
consommation d'énergie vous remettra
probablement du monde dans les activités
ouvrière et du monde dans les activités
agricoles
en tout cas si j'avais un pari à faire
avec mon propre argent c'est pour
l'évent celui là je ferai ici vous avez
une autre corrélation très intéressante
à regarder qui est l'évolution parallèle
sur les deux derniers siècles
alors évidemment c'est les calculs qui
ont permis de reconstituer sa halle et
j'allais dire des ko les kilotonnes
c'est à dire des flux d'informations et
les flux de marchandises et bien vous
voyez que là aussi il suffit pas de là
des ordinateurs partout pour un vent
moins de camions sur les routes
c'est pas comme ça que ça marche et du
reste est moins de voitures et du reste
si on veut aller vers quelque chose qui
à mon avis n'a pas de valeur probante
mais quand même une indication
intéressante il suffit de voir ce qui se
vend sur les services internes sur les
sites internet quand on prend quelque
chose c'est essentiellement des sites
qui sont des services avec de transport
yb health est un service annexe de la
poste la sncf est un endroit où vous
vendez directement du transport les
sites internet de comparateurs de prix
de billets d'avion vous vendez
directement du transport et voilà pour
tous les sites sur lesquels vous vendez
quelque chose c'est essentiellement des
services annexes des transports ça va me
permettre
non je vais pas vous dire aujourd'hui je
vous en parlerai ouvrant du bilan
carbone
ces trafiquants même angle ou l'endroit
où vous mettez les frontières du système
conditionne très souvent la conclusion
vous pouvez en tirer
là aussi vous laissez pas abuser par la
nomenclature et la manière dont on fait
les statistiques c'est pas parce qu'on
les fait d'une certaine manière que ça
veut dire que le compartiment
ils ont été pensés de telle sorte qu'ils
soient suffisants et homogène pour le
problème que vous êtes en train de
regarder
donc si vous revenez pas la définition
de ce que vous êtes en train de compter
encore quelque chose qui vous montre que
le problème est pas si simple
vous avez ici pour la france de 1970 à
2006 le l'évolution
comparez on va dire c'est que vous avez
vous avez fait une courbe en abscisses
et ordonnées vous avez pu le temps mais
vous avez en abscisse le pib on va les
constantes et en ordonnée de
consommation d'énergie dans la serre
prénom de domaine ici vous avez la
consommation de nerfs de d'électricité
est ici la consommation en transport est
ici vous avez d'énergie primaire pour la
production électrique qui est monté
beaucoup plus vite que la demande finale
alors à la question c'est est-ce que je
vais savoir faire de ses sens sont
fermés c'est ça c'est la question qu'a
de vos camarades m'a posé à l'intercours
en d'autres termes est-ce qu'on peut
vendre un projet d'économie d'énergie de
manière significative en valeur absolue
sans vendre un projet de récession c'est
pas évident c'est pas évident je les y
en a près avec ma petite règle de trois
favorites
vous allez voir c'est pas évident du
tout ce qui veut peut être dire soit dit
en passant que à partir du moment où
l'indicateur de performance qu'on
utilisait jusqu'à maintenant vous êtes à
peu près sûr qu'à l'avenir ils se
mettent à dégringoler bas mon conseil
c'est d'en changer puisque si vous en
changez pas vous êtes à peu près sûr va
voir l'algérie que des frustrations
l'exemple que je prenais à l'intercours
c'est les indicateurs de performance
qu'on prend pour sa propre vie
temple temps est votre allié ce qui est
le cas à l'âge que vous avez et bien il
ya un certain nombre d'indicateurs de
performance qu'on a envie de prendre ses
performances sportives son pouvoir de
séduction l'espace habitable pour
d'occuper pourquoi en france
et puis avec le avec l'âge y a pas un
gouvernement où le temps des plus votre
allié pour un certain nombre de ces
indicateurs
par exemple les performances sportives
en ce moment vous allez avoir tendance
histoire de pas déprimer à choisir
d'autres indicateurs dans lesquelles
vous avez toujours accès à des marges de
progrès par exemple l'argent et c'est
très exactement à mon avis un des
chantiers qui va avoir besoin d'être
faits d'entre elles dont je vous parle
c'est que si l'indicateur qui ont
utilisé jusqu'à maintenant pour des
raisons structurelles
il ya de bonnes chances pour qu'il se
mette à descendre quand l'humanité
passera son adolescence que vous avez
passé ya pas longtemps et se mettra à
vivre son âge mature et son déclin bas
en tout cas au niveau de la consommation
d'énergie il ya peut-être d'autres
indicateurs à trouver pour être capable
de gérer ça dans les meilleures
conditions possibles
tout ce que je vous ai dit jusqu'à
maintenant
et finalement quelque chose qui va être
résumées sur ce graphique c'est à dire
les économies c'est quoi exactement
l'ingénieur encore une fois il a
toujours tendance à prendre les
économies quand même c'est plus
d'efficacité énergétique donc je prends
une cafetière et je sais faire une tasse
de café chaud avec - kilowattheure je
prends une voiture et je sais faire se
déplacer une tonne de bagnols à 100 km
avec moins d'essence
je prends un mètre carré de maison et je
sais assurer confort thermique pendant
l'année avec moins d'énergie
voilà c'est en général ça son cahier des
charges dans un monde infini c'est un
bon cahier des charges très bon qui est
déjà maman d'un fils sauf que dans le
monde dans lequel on vit
si vous composez ça avec les usages la
quantité globale consommée elle elle va
aller exactement dans l'autre sens pour
le moment et encore une fois c'est
quelque chose qui est logique dans un
monde dans lequel le prix réel de
l'énergie des croix c'est parfaitement
logique
maintenant la question c'est quoi le bon
indicateur à suivre dans cette affaire
et bien comme la conviction et j'espère
que vous la partagez
c'est que les lois de la physique se
laisseront moins facilement violet
quesnoysienne et que l'accueil bleus duo
elle est assujettie au droit physique
celle là elle doit respecter les
intégrales borné 1 la production de
pétrole et de gaz et de charbon elle va
faire ça elle boit un tout petit peu
respectée la physique c'est à dire que
+5 degrés en un siècle c'est probable
que ça handicapera à l'activité humaine
suffisamment pour que le pib mondial il
arrête de faire ça il passe dans l'autre
sens en tout cas c'est ce qu'a dit
monsieur stern eh bien j'ai envie de
dire que l'emprunt efficacité
énergétique ou les vraies économies
d'énergie c'est pas de faire baisser ça
c'est faire baisser ça et là le problème
change complètement de nature parce que
peut faire un mètre carré de maison qui
consomme moins d'énergie vous avez pas
besoin de demander l'avis de la
population pour faire baisser la cave de
laudun
j'ai besoin de lui demander son avis
d'où l'explication du petit préambule
que je vous ai fait tout à l'heure sur
c'est quoi l'acceptabilité sociale en
démocratie parce que l'acceptabilité
sociale en démocratie vous l'avez dans
cette courbe même passé de kiev à la
baisse
la lidia dans la contexte agréable sans
acceptabilité sociale ou lors de toute
façon un jour à la baisse et prat dans
un contexte agréable donc cesser c'est
là ce qui fait la différence entre ces
deux courbes
encore une fois c'est passé devant un
objet à tous les objets c'est ça qui
fait la différence entre ces deux
courbes et j'insiste sur quelque chose
encore une phrase ça n'est pas le
réflexe naturel de l'ingénieur c'est le
réflexe éventuellement naturel du
gestionnaire qu'une bonne partie d'entre
vous finirez par devenir dans des
domaines techniques ou moins techniques
peu importe mais par contre ça n'est pas
le réflexe naturel de l'ingénieur ça
n'est pas non plus le réflexe naturel
chercheurs
quand vous passez dans un laboratoire de
recherche et qu'on vous dit je voudrais
un panneau photovoltaïque plus
performant on vous parle pas de la
performance de l'ensemble du parc
installé
roux pas de la performance d'un
centimètre carré de cellules donc
j'insiste encore une fois vraiment
là-dessus ça n'est pas l'inclinaison
naturelle de l'ingénieur que de se
préoccuper de la coupe du haut et
pourtant c'est là qu'est le problème
alors maintenant très rapidement c'est
quoi le pib et c'est quoi notre problème
si on le regarde de manière globale le
pib il a deux définitions et par un
grand miracle de la comptabilité ces
deux définitions sont conduisent
exactement à la même somme le pib c'est
la valeur de l'ensemble des produits et
services disponibles pour la
consommation finale donc c'est ce que le
consommateur final de quelque chose
hachette la valeur de l'ensemble ci est
acheté dans l'année alors vous voyez
bien à qu'une fois que je vous ai donné
cette définition faut se mettre d'accord
sur ce que c'est qu'un consommateur
final alors il ya des gens que vous
savez raisonnablement sortir de ce truc
là il ya des gens que vous savez plus
difficilement sortir de ce truc là
par exemple vous en ce moment vous êtes
des consommateurs finaux d'un service
d'enseignement donc quand les
statisticiens de l'insee
fond le pib a calculé le pib est bien
même si vous ne payez pas directement il
reconstitue la valeur marchande
équivalente du service d'enseignement
dont vous êtes en train de bénéficier et
crack
il vous met ça dans le pib vous allez
acheter une paire de baskets pour vous
en servir
vous êtes consommateur final de la paire
de baskets sauf que si vous allez
acheter une paire de baskets
parce que vous tenez un stade et que
vous donner gratuitement les baskets aux
gens qui payent l'entrée d'un stade à ce
moment là consommation finale c'est plus
la paire de baskets c'est l'entrée dans
le stade
donc déjà définir ce que c'est qu'une
consommation finale de quelque chose ça
peut poser des problèmes
ensuite vous avez un deuxième truc qui
peut poser problème dans cette affaire
c'est de définir ce que c'est que une
consommation en volume
parce que vous ce que vous allez payer
c'est un prix courants pour que le prix
votre paire de baskets y ait ce qui est
pris l'année prochaine il sera ce qu'il
sera sauf que les gens de l'insee ils
veulent pas mesuré la production
économique en prix courants ils veulent
enlever un truc qui s'appelle
l'inflation et l'inflation sèche pour la
même paire de baskets d'une année sur
l'autre si elle coûte 3 % de plus eh
bien je la comptabilise les suivantes à
la valeur qu'elle avait là des voiles
est apparue sur le marché
c'est sale c'est ça l'idée de la
comptabilisation en valeur et en volume
pendant oui mais cette année je vous
vends une paire de baskets avec six
trous et l'année prochaine vous envoie
une écrite puis jouer avant 5 % plus
cher est ce que c'est la même paire de
baskets avec 5% d'inflation ou est-ce
qu'à ce moment vous avez eu une
inflation ou est ce que c'est une paire
de baskets différentes et asseoir en
vous avez eu la croissance en volume
alors ça peut vous paraître cette
affaire de la sodomie diptères sauf que
si vous prenez l'exemple des voitures je
vous vois aujourd'hui une voiture qui
fait une tonne et demi et qui consomment
litres au cent et dans laquelle vous
mettez cinq personnes et puis je vous
voir l'année prochaine une voiture dans
laquelle vous mettez deux personnes qui
consomme un litre et demi au sens qui
pèse la moitié du poids
sauf que dans cette voiture vous êtes
capable d'appeler la lune à terre une
voiture c'est pas la même voiture et je
voulais vendre plus cher ses voitures ou
c'est par là une voiture
comme disait l'autre ça se discute bon
et bien on réduit le miracle de la
comptabilité publique fait que
globalement on va y aller avec voiture
d'accord donc si je vous lavant entre
autres pêcheurs et bien à ce moment
c'est d'inflation et l'inflation les
économistes m passe à une autre manière
de dire ça c'est que vous voyez bien
qu'à partir du moment où je considère
qu'un objet qui a des caractéristiques
physiques donné je ne peux pas monter
son prix sans que ce soit assimilée à de
l'inflation
ça veut dire que sur un certain nombre
d'objets que je vous ai évoqué on va
avoir énormément de mal à vendre plus
cher des objets qui consomme moins
parce que la manière dont les comptables
publics font leurs comptes aujourd'hui
font qu'ils auront très envie de compter
ça comme de l'inflation et pas de
comptes et ça comme de la croissance en
volume alors il se trouve que le pib
s'est aussi c'est un miracle de la
comptabilité publique
la somme des revenus des agents
économiques
donc en boulot c'est un empilement de
salaire de rendre le dividende de
quelques intérêts d'emprunt etc
voilà c'est ça le sait ça le in fine et
c'est toujours des choses qu'on paye à
des gens s'est jamais des choses qu'on
paye à la planète terre c'est là aussi
quelque chose que je vous ai évoqué dès
le premier cours donc dans le pib il
n'ya pas les ressources naturelles
il n'ya pas les ressources naturelles
dans le pays des on ne pourrait pas
faire secours aux mines
aujourd'hui tel qu'il est fait sans les
terres rares qui ont permis de faire
l'optique où l'écran plat tiens par
exemple de mon ordinateur sans les
combustibles fossiles qui font la petite
part d'électricité aux fossiles qui
alimente ce vidéoprojecteur sans les
noyaux d'uranium qui ont le bon goût de
se trouver dans la croûte terrestre qui
permettent d'en faire les votes parti
etc
tout ça n'est pas dans l'appréciation du
service marchand qui vous est rendu
aujourd'hui par le fait que vous êtes
capable d'avoir un court donc le pib
c'est juste le travail ou d'un qui
permet de transformer quelque chose
qu'on va trouver dans la nature en
quelque chose d'autre parce qu'on trouve
que c'est plus sympathique d'avoir un
vidéoprojecteur que
un empilement de terreur et de maillots
d'uranium mais c'est très exactement ça
le pib alors il fait vous savez ce que
c'est on peut commencer à discuter sur
est ce que il peut monter ou descendre
dans le monde contre 1 dont je vous ai
parlé alors déjà doit aussi savoir eh
bien voilà par exemple quelques unes des
composition sectorielle donc 3% du pib
aujourd'hui c'est l'énergie ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire que la somme des
revenus payés aux agents économiques
pour qu'on dispose d'énergie ces 3 % de
sondés pensent ça veut pas dire que
l'énergie permet d'avoir enfin comment
dire que l'énergie n'est nécessaire que
pour 3% du pib
aujourd'hui vous supprimez du jour au
lendemain à l'approvisionnement
énergétique du pays
et c'est pas 3% du pib qui disparaissent
dont 80 % à 10 % 1 donc ce genre de
représentation ne vous permet pas
d'appréhender l'asservissement globale
du système
ça vous donne pas de vue systémique
d'accord on à compartimenter comme ça en
gros en fonction de l'endroit où les
gens travaillent et c'est à peu près
tout ce que ça dit pour quand on vous
dit qu'elle % du pib c'est dans les
transports ça veut pas dire non plus que
si on avait trois fois moins de
transport et bien tout ce qu'on perdrait
s'est avancé de 2 à 3% du pib
non on perdra beaucoup plus que ça tel
que c'est big board et parce
qu'aujourd'hui vous n'avez quasiment pas
un produit ou service qui soit
accessible aux consommateurs sans qu'ils
aient un segment transport quelque part
vidéoprojecteur la probabilité pour que
du début du de l'extraction du minerai
de fer jusqu'au moment où ça arrive dans
cette salle tout le monde fasse ça en le
portant sur son dos ou à dos de chameau
est assez faible donc la quasi totalité
du pib mondial repose aujourd'hui sur
des transports le dernier point qu'il
faut avoir en tête c'est que le pib
correspond aux services marchands donc
quand se produisent et pour votre propre
compte
vous avez un potager c'est là dedans
vous changer une ampoule chez vous c'est
pas dedans vous participer bénévolement
à une association s'est pas dedans ça ne
correspond qu'au service marchand donc
quand elle vous dit il ya des gens qui
sont ils pas pauvre parce qu'ils vivent
avec moins de deux dollars par jour
si les gens qui vivent avec moins de
deux dollars par jour vivre sur une île
déserte avec une corne d'abondance qui
le ramène tout ce qu'il faut ils vivent
très bien alors il se trouve que dans le
monde dans lequel nous sommes
c'est clair que ça signifie qu'un
certain nombre de services ne leur
seront pas accessibles mais il faut bien
voir que deux dollars par jour
je suis pas en train de dire qu'ils sont
plus heureux ou plus valeur au goût
c'est parce que je dis que en ce qui
concerne les pays dans lesquels les
services marchands sont disponibles en
petites quantités il se trouve que par
ailleurs ce sont des pays où une bonne
partie de ce qui permet aux gens de
manger et de vivre et soit le fait de
l'auto production soit le fait de troc
c'est à dire de trucs qui échappe aux
statisticiens et aux économistes
donc là encore faut comparer ce qui est
comparable je ne dis pas que c'est mieux
ou moins bien je dis juste ça ne mesure
pas exactement la même chose
vous avez un certain nombre de trucs qui
sont très difficilement accessibles sans
les échanges marchands
quand je prends des médicaments par
exemple votre production des médicaments
et quand même pas un truc extrêmement
répandues par contre vous avez des tas
de trucs qui peuvent largement échappé
aux échanges marchands votre production
des vaccins et on vous avez des trucs
qui peuvent très largement échappé aux
échanges marchands centrale est
signification particulière et ça peut
nous permettre l'agriculture vivrière
donc faut faire très attention quand on
manipule ce terme à bien se rappeler ce
qu'il signifie et du coup encore une
fois toutes les limites
et là je vous assure ce que je vous ai
dit sur les députés tout à l'heure en ce
qui concerne l'énergie
c'est aussi la trouvera sur le pib je
veux maintenant en iran fin de cette
partie sur les économies où je vous ai
dis encore une fois je vous ai tout dit
techniquement et techniquement que faire
des économies partout c'est vraiment pas
un problème vous prenez n'importe quel
objet qu par unité du hc facile la
question c'est de mettre en perspective
les économies unitaire avec nos sous et
économique et l'acceptabilité sociale
mais pour ça je vais utiliser une
équation il n'ya pas longtemps on m'a
dit tiens c'est un anagramme de yakaar
mais en fait c'est il ya vraiment un
monsieur callas dur et gelé vraiment
rencontré certains japonais et il dit je
vais prendre mes émissions de co2 ce
qu'on veut commencer juste le co2 sur
lequel devaient disserter je vais dire
que le co2 est égal au co2 ce qui
normalement devrait encore vous est
accessible à cette heure ci est ensuite
je divise et je multiplie par trois
permanents nul successivement la
quantité d'énergie qu'on consomme le
produit économique marchand et la
population mondiale et pourquoi est ce
que un quart d'heure de la cantine c'est
un truc intéressant pour les raisons
suivantes
c'est que ça permet d'exprimer les
émissions de gaz carbonique comme le
produit de cap terme sur lequel chaque
spécialiste dans son domaine va avoir
une vision conventionnelle de l'avenir
ici ça va être le domaine de
l'énergéticien et ou du physicien ça et
ça ça va être les domaines de
l'ingénieur
l'ingénieur et sait faire deux choses
dans cette histoire il sait faire des
dispositifs qui sont plus efficaces en
énergie par unité économique
c'est-à-dire par le jld
donc il sait faire une cafetière qui
consomme moins d'énergie il sait faire
ça c'est pour les trucs qui s'est fait
un nom qui doit savoir faire et il se
fait un deuxième truc qui est de fournir
de l'énergie en ayant une vie moins de
co2 ça c'est le royaume du nucléaire des
renouvelables de la capture et la
séquestration etc
et ça c'est le royaume
des économies unitaire c'est à dire une
voiture un frigo 1 m² de logements la
fabrication d'un stylo à bille et c'est
tout ça on est en consommer moins
d'énergie ça c'est le royaume des
économistes les économistes il
s'intéresse à aux produits économiques
marchands et par personne et à la
manière dont il évolue et ça c'est le
royaume des démographes question est ce
que tous ces gens là sont d'accord entre
eux où est-ce qu'ils sont pas d'accord
entre eux
on va commencer par demander aux gens
qui sont dans la partie gauche de
l'équation qui sont près des lois
physiques difficiles à violer ou
mathématiques difficile à violer ils
vous disent il faut diviser par deux les
émissions de gaz carbonique mondiale as
soon as possible
et de toute façon même si on n'y arrive
pas à soon as possible
on y arrivera juste un peu plus tard à
cause de la limitation sur les
combustibles fossiles et sur les
surfaces de forêt à défricher
après vous allez faire un petit tour à
l'institut d'études démographiques et
vous l'a dit est ce que la population
est parti pour la diviser par deux parce
que ça pourrait être une manière toutes
choses égales par ailleurs de respecter
l'égalité et l'institut d'études
démographiques dit ça m'étonnerait sauf
chute de météorite guerre atomique
mondiale ou grippe aviaire
ça devrait plutôt augmenter de 50 % dans
les cinq ans qui viennent
alors je vous en fais une chose en ce
qui concerne la population l'avenir
n'est pas plus écrit que pour le reste
et il n'existe pas de prévisions
démographiques
il existe des projections démographiques
il n'existe pas de prévisions
démographiques
ça n'existe pas il n'existe pas de
prévisions du poste que vous occuperez à
20 ans dans 20 ans pardon ça n'existe
pas on peut on peut évaluer les
probabilités mais on peut pas dire qu'on
va faire une prévision n'existe pas là
c'est exactement pareil on est trop loin
d'une loi avec un caractère prédictif or
toi qui vas te dire c'est comme ça que
ça va se passer
on peut dire c'est plus probable
d'accord on peut dire que c'est ce sur
quoi on se base d'accord mais ça n'est
pas une prévision stricto sensu
donc si on prend la vision classique de
l'avenir de démographie 10 + 50 %
si 50 ans donc là vous voyez que on doit
gagner un facteur 2 sur le terme de
gruchet on prend un facteur 2 mais dans
l'autre sens sur le terme de droite un
facteur 5 pardon sur le terme de droite
ça veut donc dire que les trois termes
qui reste on doit les corriger leurs
acteurs trois corps on doit faire / fois
sur les trois termes qui reste alors
ensuite je vais voir monsieur attali et
je lui dis est-ce qu'on va diviser le
pib dans personnes par trois monsieur
attali me répond non il faut sauver les
retraites
assurer la marche de leclerc 1 et de
l'emploi pour tous pour les ingénieurs
donc on va augmenter sa de 2% par an sur
les 50 ans qui viennent
vous savez comme moi à faire des
intérêts composés du reste peut-être que
certains d'entre vous iront en faire
leur métier chez un banquier plus tard
si vous faites 1,02 à la puissance 50
ça vous fait en deux un facteur 3 à
l'échelle de 45 50 ans et c'est
tellement sensible au dos il y avait il
quelque chose initiale que on va se
limiter aux premiers chiffres
significatifs et on va dire que ça s'est
multipliée par trois en 50 ans donc la
vision conventionnelle de l'avenir c'est
joli mr par 2 et je multiplie ses
d'autres cas par quatre et demi ça veut
donc dire que les ingénieurs merveilleux
vous êtes et moi aussi
on va devoir faire un facteur naissent
disons 10 sur les deux termes qui reste
alors je commence par convoquer les gens
de ma génération et les gens de la
génération précédente
en dix ans sur l'intensité énergétique
de l'économie la montre et moi ce que
vous avez réussi à faire et les
ingénieurs me dise voilà en trente ans
on a réussi à faire 30 % donc là il
fallait un d'énergie pour faire 1 de pib
il ya trente ans maintenant il faut 07
d'énergie pour faire 1 de pib
il ya eu deux chocs pétroliers dans
l'intervalle et je peux vous assurer
comme aiguillon
ça a été assez sensible vous montrerez
après ben je vais continuer
tendanciellement sur cette affaire là il
est possible d'aller plus vite qu'eux
next big air par exemple là on va rester
ce qu'il ya des avantages et des
inconvénients mais là on va rester sur
la prolongation torrentielles et à ce
moment on dit que on va gagner un
facteur 2 en 50 ans incidemment dire
qu'on gagne un facteur 2 en 50 ans là
dessus comme le produit de nos trois
permis de dresser la quantité d'énergie
consommée par l'humanité vous voyez que
si ici je divise par deux là je
multiplie par 3 et là je multiplie par
1,5
ça veut dire qu on est dans un contexte
dans lequel la quantité globale
d'énergie consommée par l'humanité
double d'accord donc plus 50% croissance
démographique et + 2 % de pib par
personne sur les 50 ans qui viennent
avec un gain de 50% sur l'efficacité
énergétique mondiale ça veut dire en
veut deux fois plus d'énergie à fournir
dans 50 ans 45 et à ce moment je passe
une petite annonce et jodie cherche
ingénieurs astucieux qui sont capables
de me faire un facteur 4 sur ce terme là
où la génération précédente a pas su
faire mieux que 10 % en 30 ans voilà
c'est très exactement ça qu'il faut
c'est des gens qui vont être capables de
faire un facteur 4 là dessus pour que
l'on puisse prolonger l'adhérence de
manière conventionnelle et vous voyez
bien que si ça et ça ne sont ou
techniquement ou économiquement ou
socialement pas un reporter et ben
l'égalité ayant une très sale manie
c'est que les deux termes sont égaux
c'est là dedans et là dedans que ça va
taper donc ce que je suis en train de
vous dire c'est que les questions
énergétiques
c'est un enjeu de société absolument
fondamental et centrale et leur
négligence ne garantit pas qu'on va
avoir une économie de plus en plus
prospère avec de temps en temps les
écolos qui gagne dans le journal ces
garanties une forme d'effondrement une
forme d'effondrement dans les décennies
siècle probablement avant 2100 et
peut-être même bien avant traduire cette
hausse soit dit en passant très
exactement message du club de rang
dont je vous ai parlé dans le premier
cours ça veut dire que la vision
conventionnelle elle devrait prolonger
cette courbe vous avez les hydrocarbures
la charbon pétrole et gaz qui ont cru et
embellit jusqu'en 2005 2006 2007 et bien
il faut le prolonger de cette manière
alors moins 1,5 pour cent par an sur les
énergies fossiles je vais vous montrer
comment on fait c'est très simple plus
la personne qu'on sent par an sur les
renouvelables et nucléaire on en parlera
dans les deux prochains cours pour voir
si c'est un truc qui est envisageable ou
pas envisageable mais c'est très
exactement ça qu'il faut faire si on
veut avoir à la fois le pib pour tous et
apprennent d'environnement alors pour
avoir moins de 5% sur les énergies
fossiles je vais aller directement à la
conclusion c'est extrêmement simple il
suffit de monter le prix extrêmement
simple il suffit de monter le prix plus
vite que ce que les gens gagnant c'est
d'une simplicité biblique et je vais
vous montrer deux ou trois exemples qui
part a donc retenu les économies
d'énergie c'est le prix c'est le prix et
je disais tout à l'heure je ne compte
pas le nombre d'ingénieurs des mines les
vallées x-mines par les autodidactes
comme moi qui ont au terme d'un parcours
qui a duré n'importe quoi entre 3 et 10
ans dans les affaires énergétiques qui
ne seraient plus qu'à parler d'argent cc
ils font tous tous tous exactement le
même parcours et même les autodidactes
comme moi il à comprendre pourquoi donc
j'en reviens à ce que je vous disais
vous avez ici les émissions de co2 par
secteur de la france entre 1960 et 2000
à 2002 qu'importe vous voyez que dans la
période de la fin des trente glorieuses
toutes les émissions sectorielle
augmentent s'il vous plaît il y en a
encore pour cinq minutes en tout les
émissions sectorielle augmente donc ici
vous l'avez les émissions de l'industrie
ici vous avez des émissions de
l'électricité qui à cette époque
tournent majoritairement fioul
ici vous avez les émissions du
résidentiel et tertiaire sur les
bâtiments ici celle des transports
ici celle de l'agriculture lors
l'agriculture est un peu particulier
parce que là dedans vous avez les brûlis
en bout de champ vous nous avez fait les
combustibles fossiles et c'est voulu
tout s'accroît l'embellie est la
première augmentation du prix et la
deuxième augmentation du prix
ac c'est absolument spectaculaire dans à
peu près tous les secteurs sauf le
transport mais j'y viendrai après vous
avez un arrêt à la hausse puis une
baisse alors l'art et à la hausse il est
d'abord due à la récession
c'est l'effet de très court terme marche
très bien et ensuite le signal prix est
devenue suffisamment élevé pour que
d'état d'investissement qui permet
d'économiser de l'énergie deviennent
économiquement rentable donc c'est là
qu'on commence à voir apparaître la
réglementation réglementation thermique
sur les bâtiments ont construit plus
cher mais ça consomme moins c'est là
qu'on commence à voir apparaître des
gens qui vont faire des arbitrages sur
la manière dont ils produisent dans
l'industrie et vous avez des tas
d'endroits où le fait d'économiser de
l'industrie de l'énergie devient un truc
important donc ça va faire sortir plus
vite les découvrir des laboratoires etc
alors le transport pourquoi est-ce que
la hausse n'a pas été cassé
parce qu'en fait le signal a été trop
bref pour pour cela vous allez voir que
pour le transport il faut un signal l'on
est par contre ça a eu un effet très
discernable sur la partie rapidement
variable qui est les achats de voitures
réalisées dans l'année ici vous avez une
club que je vous avais montré lors du
premier cours qui est le prix du pétrole
en dollars constants depuis 1860
et vous voyez que en 1981 on est passé
par un maximum en dollars constants
concombre et atteint tout juste
actuellement 1
un maximum en dollars constants et il se
trouve que le prix à la pompe
ils ont rattrapé le maximum pendant les
années qui ont suivi c'est à dire que en
france et dans la majeure partie des
pays d'europe et du monde
les prix à la pompe ils ont augmenté
entre 1981 et 1985
issa le rattrapage s'est pas fait
instantanément et c'est à partir de 85
qu'on a eu ce qu'on a appelé le
contrechoc tient que les prix à la pompe
et les prix des services ont bien baissé
eh bien regardez le comportement du
consommateur entre 1981 et 1985 dans un
certain nombre de pays de cdo et
l'italie la france la grande bretagne et
la moyenne et caetera et bien le
consommateur dans tous ces pays
indépendamment de qui il avait élu
l'année précédente et de la marque du
concessionnaire du coin ils ont tous le
même comportement
c'est à dire que d'une année sur l'autre
la consommation de véhicules neufs
vendus dans l'année besse et en 1985
année du contrat choc l'âme pour même
moment indépendamment du concessionnaire
du coin des publicités vues à la télé et
de la personne qu'ils ont eue l'année
précédente
instantanément le consommateur arrêtent
d'acheter des modèles plus économes
d'une année sur l'autre
c'est là je pense que vous avez vraiment
un message absolument fondamental et
vous voyez bien que encore une fois
c'est pas dépendant de la couleur du
parti politique au pouvoir
c'est indépendant des marques dominantes
de voitures vendues dans le pays
c'est pas dépendants des autoroutes qui
existent ou qui n'existe pas etc c'est
indépendant de tout ça c'est d'une
homogénéité absolument parfaite
alors il se trouve que ce signal s'est
appliqué en france
mais quand vous regardez à l'époque
qu'elle était la croissance annuelle du
parc de voitures et la croissance du pib
par personne et de l'accès aux
transports motorisés
cette évolution là qui concerne un litre
de sang de baisse
en quelques années n'a pas été
suffisante pour que sur les émissions
totales du parc on est une baisse sarah
simplement un tout petit peu amorti la
russe sur une année ou deux années voilà
c'est tout l'effet que ça a eu parce que
lacombe que vous avez assez la
composition d
véhicules neufs vendus dans l'année avec
le parc était déjà existants avec
l'augmentation du kilométrage par
personne avec l'accès à l'âme au vide et
à la mobilité motorisée dans votre
ensemble personnes donc ça n'a pas été
maintenue suffisamment longtemps pour
avoir un effet alors maintenant on va
regarder ce que ça donne quand on le
maintient suffisamment longtemps pour
avoir un effet et c'est ce que vous avez
sur ce graphique vous avez ici la
consommation d'énergie dans les
transports routiers alors ici c'est les
giga joule
pour une fois on était orthodoxe au
niveau du sii en du système
international pardon paradis 15 ans en
fonction de prix à la pompe du carburant
le prix à la pompe du carburant c'est
quelque chose qui est un signal lent car
il ya eu deux philosophies pratiqué en
la matière dans les pays consommateurs
d'énergie
c'est ou bien les pays ont consommé ont
commencé par dont leur histoire
industrielle avec de l'énergie à
profusion donc en étant producteur de
pétrole cas des états unis par exemple
et à ce moment les prix à la pompe sont
bas et du reste dans tous les pays
producteurs aujourd'hui les prix à la
pompe sont bas les pays qui sont
historiquement producteurs qui sont bas
ou bien les pays on consomme on commence
et je vais y arriver
l'art histoire industrielle avec une
absence d'hydrocarbures liquides sur
leur sol ce qui est le cas de la
totalité des pays d'europe occidentale
le pétrole en grande bretagne ses 74
donc les grands bretons ils ont commencé
à conduire sans exploitation pétrolière
sur leurs sols et à ce moment les
carburants sont significativement taxe
et il n'y a pas de différentiel
significatif de fiscalité sur les
carburants entre les divers pays
d'europe occidentale n'a pas et vous
voyez que donc ce signal là il est même
parce que il est le résultat d'une
histoire qui était producteur pas
producteur et c'est un signal qui a été
maintenu sur des dizaines d'années et
bien le résultat de ces de ce signal
maintenue sur des dizaines d'années
c'est que vous verrez vous n'êtes pas
très loin d'avoir une hyperbole sur
cette affaire-là
c'est à dire que plus on a maintenu
pendant longtemps un prix élevé
pompes et bien les gens consomment de
carburants routiers par an d'une manière
générale ils voient aussi qu'on se faire
moins de kilomètres
utiliser des modèles qui consomment
moins aussant qui devait être et c'est
ce que je suis en train de vous dire là
c'est que la technologie elle va
s'investir
là où le prix de l'énergie lui dit
d'aller si le prix de l'énergie montrent
plus vite que le pouvoir d'achat la
technologie ear à s'investir dans une
réduction des usages gogo si le prix
monte moins vite que le pouvoir d'achat
décent à la technologie et hier à
s'investir dans l'augmentation des
usages plus vite que dans la baisse d'un
usage particulier donc en rire le
progrès technique il existe et il
existera toujours tant qu'il y aura des
gens pour s'en occuper
par contre là où il va s'investir dépend
fondamentalement du prix de l'énergie
ces salles élément fondamental et c'est
pas très étonnant si vous vous rappelez
encore une fois du premier cours
quand je vous ai dit l'énergie c'est l
aptitude à transformer le monde donc le
prix de la transformation du monde et
allianz quelque chose qui est assez
structurant sur la manière dont se
comporte le monde voilà si vous
prolonger cette courbe va vous arriver à
la conclusion que pour que la
consommation de carburants en france
soit divisée d'un facteur 4
eh bien il faut en gros arriver à 4
euros par litre 15 $ par litre pas en un
jour pendant un jour mais c'est là qu'il
faut varier et ici je vais finir avec
deux graphes qui vous montre les gains
envisageable à l'échelle mondiale en ce
qui concerne les émissions de co2 en
fonction du prix auquel on met la tonne
d'équivalent co2 donc en d'autres termes
si un signal prix est envoyé à
l'ensemble de l'économie mondiale
en dix ans la tonne de co2 elle va
valoir 50 50 $ et bien à ce moment
l'économie mondiale pas encore un
scénario tendanciel est capable
d'économiser entre 10 et 25 milliards
de tonnes équivalent co2 voilà c'est ça
que dit ce graphique et vous verrez que
c'est à lancer une population de toutes
les études qui ont été faites sur le
sujet que le giec a réalisé et vous
voyez que vous preniez le truc en
bétonnant pour un top down c'est à dire
en compilant de trucs micro ou en ayant
une approche directement macro le signe
là la conclusion est toujours la même
plume et monter le prix plus de gens
feront d'économies voilà donc c'est
clairement encore une fois quelque chose
qui n'est plus un enseignement technique
mais j'en reviens à le message central
de secours
c'est que les économies d'énergie c'est
pour encore plus que la technique une
questions d'acceptabilité sociale donc
économique c'est ça les économies
d'énergie dernier avant dernier
graphique vous avez ici
cette décomposition percepteur évolué et
c'est par hasard que le bâtiment
émergent le plus fort dans les
discussions actuelles
vous voyez que là elle vous fait le plus
d'économies avec un co2 qui serait
n'importe quoi entre 20 et 100 euros la
tonne
c'est dans le bâtiment ensuite c'est
dans les industries de l'énergie donc
nucléaire et renouvelables ça peut
basculer
surtout nucléaire et séquestration ça
peut basculer très vite si vous avez un
petit signal prix pas très élevées sur
la plaine de co2 dans l'industrie lourde
la fabrication des matériaux est
extrêmement énergivore et je peux vous
dire que 100 euros la tonne de co2 pour
mittal ou 100 euros la tonne de co2 pour
une plainte c'est pas un signal qui est
mineure alors que sur un litre d'essence
ça se verra à peine parce que 20 euros
la tonne ça vous fait 4 centimes en plus
un donc 100 euros la tonne de co2 ça
vous fait 20 centimes en plus je veux
dire c'est pas ça va pas empêcher les
gens voulaient alors 100 euros la tonne
de co2 sur des procédés industriels il
ya des endroits où ça peut radicalement
changer les procédés vous faisiez du
nickel avec des fourmis 400° vous les
faites avec des procédés acide base à 20
degrés ça changera tout petit peu la
consommation d'énergie
dans les transports vous voyez que c'est
là que la réduction est la plus
inélastique au prix c'est ce que je vous
disais tout à l'heure il faut il faut il
faut maintenir le signal très longtemps
parce que là c'est à l'échelle de 20 ans
il faut maintenir le signal très
longtemps parce que les transports ont
structuré d'urbanisme et une fois que
vous avez l'urbanisme que vous avez vous
le détricoter pas en un jour et à ce
moment pour que le truc vivre
correctement vous avez des besoins en
transport pas facile donc c'est c'est
quelque chose encore une fois que qui
est vraiment le message central de
secours
c'est que les économies d'énergie c'est
avant tout une affaire d'argent et si je
résume en gros la manière dont le
problème se pose à nous aujourd'hui
avant de parler des nucléaire et
renouvelables et de la suite voilà un
bilan provisoire qu'on peut tirer de
cette affaire qui est qu'on arrive de
l'état de gauche
on s'est mis provisoirement dans l'état
du milieu et toute la question est de
savoir si avec de moins en moins
d'énergie fossile on va refaire et à
gauche
aussi si personnellement m'intéresserait
beaucoup plus non on va se mettre dans
l'état du haut c'est à dire qu'il va y
avoir une manière de transition femmes
transition pour continuer à avoir
exactement les mêmes usages
qu'aujourd'hui sans énergie fossile donc
ça ça nous emmène aux deux cours qui
vont suivre
c'est à dire nucléaire et renouvelables
donc on se retrouve lundi prochain pour
parler du nucléaire jeudi prochain pour
parler des renouvelables et bel appétit